I like to call myself a motivational
doer I hate talking too much when
Hollywood stops valuing me I'm done real
toughness is when you can tell people
you know I'm in pain I don't feel good
right now need motivation watch a top 10
with believe nation what's that belief
nation it's 7 this channel is designed
to be a part of your daily success
routine and help you believe in your
Michael Jordan level talent so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from being terrorized by an abusive and
alcoholic father to becoming a highly
successful artist athlete and actor he's
Terry Crews and here's my take on his
top 10 Rose a success vol 2 also if you
want to know what Terry and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confident series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a free morning video to
help you build your confidence the link
is in the description below whatever
you're thinking about it you will not
get it until you take action you gotta
get rid of those haters in your mind
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one just go for it my mom passed away
about almost three years ago and she
always would tell me she was like
whatever you do I know you're doing all
this football stuff you're doing a lot
of other things but never forget you're
an artist babe you're an artist I'm
telling you when I see what I'm doing
right now and I get to I get to do so
many things that so many people never
got to see I get to go so many places
and do so many things that none of the
people who wanted to were able to I feel
like just there is a responsibility but
also if I don't do it everything they've
gone through it's nothing you know so
the way I approach things is really it's
kind of for everyone else you know I
have to try it I have to go for it I
like this call myself a motivational
doer I hate talking so much like I'm a
big talker and you guys you can tell but
the big thing is I want to back
everything up with action I want to be
an action figure
like always always back it up with
movement don't talk about working out
you can do it all day but do it and that
was the big big distinction I've seen
especially growing up in the hood so
many people man I'm gonna do this I'm
finna I'm finna and man I said man well
why haven't you why aren't you and so
everything you see me doing I just said
I'm going I'm trying I'm going for it I
don't care and we'll see what happens
rule number two go where you're valued
I've done over 600 hours of television
okay non-stop today even counting the
movies even counting over 60 may
your films let me tell you something
life begins and I look I'm not even done
I'm designed a furniture right now I'm
my own furniture line out right now look
I don't even know what I'll be doing let
me sit and see the thing is you gotta
know who's battling valuing you when NFL
stopped valuing me I was done when
Hollywood stops valuing me I'm done you
cannot let people treat you like you are
not valuable and then I'll move on to
the next thing I'll be sitting there
painting on the corner I only go where
I'm invited I'll only go where I'm
valued and that's it that's it when
you've done valuing me out but the
problem is these dangling carrots people
got they got people running around hey
take your clothes off do some crazies in
there and they want you dangling carrots
I'm like no I do it when you see me
doing anything I'm doing I wanted to do
it in fact it's about thing you know you
see Old Spice I came up with that rule
number three find your true purpose
I know people who spend time at the job
and I'm waiting for the clock to strike
five in fact if you leave five minutes
before it's time to go you're stealing
your stealing you do not understand your
purpose in the workplace you do not
understand what your purpose is and I'm
telling you if you find out and this
takes some soul-searching it takes some
digging but your purpose it will give
you everything you need rule number four
chase perfection
I've always been left-handed right
brained and very visual about everything
in my life and I remember it was I have
an older brother and a younger sister
and when my mom was uh when my brother
was off to school I was about 4 you know
five years ago I hadn't gone to
kindergarten yet I used to just sit and
draw all day long and it was something
where I remember being inside of a
painting or a picture or a drawing and
time would stop I would be there for
almost I I remember starting a ping or
whatever and it would turn in tonight it
would be eight hours have gone by
and it felt like literally 20 minutes
and I got better and better and and but
but this is a deal to is that I was
always always disappointed as an artist
because it never looked the way I wanted
it to look so every drawing every
painting became this effort to make what
was in my head match what was on the
paper and I'm still doing that I mean in
regards to performances in regards to
drawing in regards to my furniture in
regards to all the things that I've ever
tried to do it's still not as good as it
is in my head and that's crazy it is
it's weird but I think my whole life has
been trying to match up with this thing
in this vision that I have in my head
and I don't think I'll ever get there
but it's fun to try rule number five get
what you want
everybody getting used yeah you go to a
job whatever the god the boss wants all
he wants out of you that's right but if
you don't get what you're supposed to
get you messed up that's right no matter
what that if my job is cleaning and
picking up and doing my thing and I'm
like I got a bad attitude and not making
it happen it's gonna suck for me but if
I'm like yo wait a minute I can get a
business I hire some other people to
clean and then you look you got a
janitor job you got a whole janitor
position where you could turn this thing
into a business then you took everything
you needed to take out of that job it's
a different mindset and I'm telling you
yes you were being used
yes but get everything you're supposed
to get and move on
rule number six be vulnerable what what
does manhood mean to you because for so
many people I think manhood means a
certain amount of masculinity a certain
amount of you know holding that egg not
letting it crack like you said you know
how do you crack that egg when did you
realize that you know a certain amount
of masculine
shredding wasn't the right way to pay
for me right like you said people think
about that masculine thing for me it was
exactly the opposite I had to get in
touch with my feminine side yeah to
become a true man because let me tell
you the Marlboro guy he's always by
himself
you know but the problem is his wife
can't talk to him his kids can't talk to
him he's marching off on a horse by
himself
and let me say he goes to the woodshed
and he's crying at 55 because he's all
alone and I realized that is what was
gonna happen to me if I did not stop
this macho thing and really just come in
and touch with what my kids wanted and
you know cuz I have four girls and it
was hard it was weird cuz I said hey
what's wrong and they didn't want to
talk to me you start to realize man I
don't want that future you know what I
mean I don't want that I don't want them
to see me as an adversary I want them to
see me as a friend and I had to really
just stop and come out of my own world
and most guys they feel like it's being
you know being soft and being cushy and
whatever but get saw get cushy and
understand that you know really really
real toughness is when you can tell
people you're hurting real toughness is
when you can tell people you know I'm in
pain I don't feel good right now you
know there was a time I wouldn't allow
myself to be sad I used to be like okay
all right we're gonna do some fun right
now and what's happening I was blocking
out every bad thing in my life
and what I needed to do was deal with it
and some days I just said how did you
deal with it it's weird I mean something
just by acknowledging it just
acknowledging it talking to you I talked
to my wife about it I'll talk to my kids
about it when my kids come to me they
don't have to be happy there you go dad
I just don't feel good today and I'll
hug them and say you know what that's
how it is sometime rule number seven
believe I gotta know I mean growing up
in Flint there were a number of
obstacles I mean crazy crazy obstacles
because I grew up and the I mean at the
height of the crack epidemic and also
the demise of the auto industry so there
were two things happening at once and
they were both horribly bad I mean I my
it was like the 80s
probably late 70s all the way through
the 80s into the 90s was literally the
walking dead and it was real I mean you
had people who were cracked out I had
friends family who one day you know
whatever good people the next day they
were stealing everything you had all the
way to everyone you knew were losing
their jobs and it was a panic and I
remember there was two ways out and one
was through music and performing another
way with athletics but are never you
couldn't get paid doing art you know
what I mean
it was got everybody like that's a
wonderful picture but it's you're a
starving artist that's the whole term
you know and I remember just saying okay
I'm gonna do this art thing but I had to
do the football thing too and these were
my ways out now I didn't believe that I
was actually going to get any kind of
light as an artist but I had one teacher
one man mr. Eichelberger I'll never
forget this and he was like a buttery
you are an amazing artist he was like
I'm the art teacher you're better than
me and he said you can go somewhere with
this and I was like okay but you know
nobody's gonna pay you know buddy's
gonna pay me to do this nobody it's it's
good but I I gotta use football well he
filled out all the applications for me
and I didn't even know wow this is crazy
and he took my pictures and my paintings
and everything that I did he took and
got a photograph did all this stuff sent
him to Interlochen Arts Academy not
Interlaken it's just world-famous big
deal big big deal arts camp up in
northern Michigan near Traverse City and
you study with people from all over the
world and he literally take came to me
and told me he already filled out
everything and he said Terry you have a
scholarship from Chrysler bull ride to
go to Interlochen Arts Academy and
like what are you talking about like you
know first of all I didn't think it was
possible this is the deal there's a lot
of things you know it's weird because
you gotta let people believe in you but
I didn't believe in myself and when I
got a chance to go to inter locket and
study with people from Europe and from
Brazil and from and these was mainly
music students and then add art students
and it was just as like a cover from
Flint I mean coming from the hood and
then once I did this change my life once
I remember we had an and it was really
big on competition very very big on
competition it was like if you were a
violinist you had to be the first chair
and second chair and I remember all
these kids they were disappointed
because they kept moving down and it
would just feel like they were crushed
and the same thing with art they gave us
to paint we had to do two drawings and
we had the whole class doing all these
drawings and they said put those
drawings on the wall and don't put your
name on them we have the this the sky
coming from from the Cleveland Institute
of Art he's gonna judge each painting
and we want to see who's the best and I
was like oh man you know and so I did my
deal and I put all it was a wall full of
art and the the the art guy pointed at
mine and he said that one's the best one
then he went all the way across the room
and he said that one and they were both
mine I was like
now life is a confidence game then you
could tell me nothing oh damn it I'm
good I got too arrogant I got arrogant
you have to be humbled some other way
you know but that would let me know I
was like walking I can do it I can do it
like I'm really is good these people
this is all over the world and then I
got a scholarship to Western Michigan
University and art will number eight
being control of your life happiness
think people think happiness is all
about money
happiness is never ever about money
happiness is about being able to control
your own life that's all you want
uh-huh it don't matter what you got in
your bank but if you can control your
own life you're happy that's the beauty
and that's where everybody's mixed up
yeah because you got all this money but
if somebody else is controlling you rule
number nine
speak up my earliest memory since I was
a kid and I remember I get one of my
earliest things it was like four or five
years old it's my father
hitting my mother in the face as hard as
he could and she gets knocked out and I
remember seeing her on the floor and
then looking at him this giant of a man
who I thought my god he says he loves
her what is he gonna do to me
and all I could think I want to protect
you I want to protect her and how long
it was and I said I got to be strong and
I got to get strength so that I can
protect her and every time he came home
we were scared we didn't know I
literally wet the bed till I was 14
years old because I didn't know
was gonna happen I would wake up - glass
breaking sounds people screaming and it
was a nightmare we lived a nightmare for
years and I remember my mother coming
into our room and saying we leave it
pack our stuff we're out of here and we
will grab everything we had and we put
it in garbage bags and we're tired up
and we wait to go and then she come back
here and she said we can't go you can't
leave what am I gonna go and I just
remember feeling like let's go anywhere
I don't care we could be a street but
she couldn't do it and he went on
terrorizing us terrorizing us forever
and it was like what could we do what I
was taught and in my hood and my area is
that be simply because I was a man I was
more valuable than the women in my life
that is a that was a firm belief and
Here I am I'm like you know I watched my
mother get abused
but here I as a man I felt like hey it's
my way or the highway I remember times
with my daughter as real and I would
yell at her as if she was a thirty year
old man and I remember these times and I
I remember I constantly apologize
constantly call them and say I'm sorry
I'm sorry daddy didn't get it daddy
missed it and this I couldn't believe
what was happening cuz here I was a very
successful man very successful but what
you have to realize is that success is
the warmest place to hide you have to
realize that people can't they can't
quantify the fact that you know this guy
is such a successful producer how could
he do these damaging thing
this guy's a world-class athlete how
could he be this way
this guy's a professor and he's so
intelligent how could he do this stuff
this guy is a wonderful politician how
could this happen
success is the warmest place to hide
everyone here you get it you get it but
you have to go out and spread the word
find one person find one one person that
can help and I'm telling you this right
now for me this is my calling
this is more valuable you know I'm
promoting movies and TV shows and the
whole thing but I want to talk about
this I want to talk about this because
when people understand that it does not
matter what you look like it doesn't
matter anyone anywhere it can be
victimized and no man woman or child
should ever put up with being treated as
less than a human being ever ever and
rule number ten the last one before a
very special bonus clip is have fun
clothes bags bodies baby will make you
feel so powerful to blow your mind right
in front of your face
automatic freshness softness and static
control has never been easier with the
bounce dryer but I just stick it to the
inside of my dryer and I never have this
so powerful it sells itself and other
people's commercials
you smell like outdoor festivals you
smell like
I've got a really special bonus clip
from Terry on how to change the way you
think that I think you're gonna really
enjoy but before that it's time for the
free point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life and
in your business so answer these three
questions number one where do you feel
undervalued and when will you leave that
place number two where do you need to
speak up for yourself and what are you
going to do about it and number three
what is your true purpose
tene 86 that was my senior year in high
school and we were I was we I went to
Flint Academy and it was a classy school
but we were highly ranked in the state
and I was used to be a basketball player
I mean I was yeah hard to believe now
but basketball it was a big sport for me
but I was the starting sinner on this
team and what was wild as we were picked
to go all the way in the state we had a
superstar on our team and we had a
really really good team but we had a we
played against the school who decided
not to play it was the district
championship it was right the beginning
of the playoffs and these guys would
take the ball down the court and pass
the ball to each other at the top of the
court and wouldn't play and our we had a
coach who was like well you know what
I'm gonna beat you at your own game so
we stayed in a zone so we sitting at a
whole time and I'm telling us the most
boring game of all time we just sat
there with our hands up and they pass
the ball and if anything happened
somebody went and got it and it was
score two and it was just a mess so the
score was really really low and it they
were up 47 to 45 and it was literally
under a minute and I'm freaking out
because now we're going to it's evident
we're going to lose because I'm going
man this is a dumb like defensive
strategy anyway we should have been
going after it but what happened is a
guy threw the ball there guy threw the
ball cross-court i intercepted it and
with literally five seconds left to go
and I take the ball all the way down the
court you got to understand I'm thinking
I had visions of oh my god this is the
thing I'm the hero you know the heart is
like pounding you just you I'm already
at the party you know and I go with this
layer
and I bring it up there and it's totally
it gets around the rim and it rolls and
let me tell you that place goes nuts
because it was the upset of the year and
I collapsed in a heap and I know my life
is over and you gotta understand and
this is another thing
shame among men it's like oh how could
you do that yeah other players were
yelling at me the coach at the I was in
the locker room he was like you had no
business taking that shot and I stole
the ball it wasn't like we didn't have a
shot anyway but he was like you have no
business taking that shot you should
have passed it man it's your fault and
the people and everybody in the room was
like yeah and I was like they didn't let
me off one and I remember just going oh
my god and I went in the paper and the
paper next day was like Terry Crews had
a shot and he messed you know and let me
say it was the most dark I mean when you
when you're you know 16 years old I was
poor I mean beyond Christ I and one guy
was taunting me I got enough I ate after
the school and the whole thing and I was
just like this is awesome oh it's
horrible
and so it was a couple days went by and
I was in the deepest bump I'm sitting on
my bed and I shared my room with my
brother but for some reason he wasn't
there because I always remember being
there it was kind of great I don't ever
remember being alone except that time
and I remember being alone and just
thinking about man what I should have
passed it I should have passed it maybe
I messed up and you know what else could
I have done and then another little
voice it said I took the shot I took the
shot and I was I I did I did and it was
kept and I kept thinking it was like man
look when you had the chance when
everything was on the line
took your shot man you did that you did
that and all of a sudden I was like
that's right that's right I took it and
I learned from then on I said man wait a
minute if I if I win or if I fail it's
going to be on my terms
it's going to be up to me ah if I have
the opportunity I have to go for it and
then I felt really good about losing
again it was red it was totally now this
you can call it reframing a lot of
people have scientific ways or
psychological ways to you know to do
thing but I learned always to kind of
reframe things so that it's to your
advantage you know what I mean and you
look at these things like wait a minute
you took the shot man and I and this is
another thing because what's so crazy is
that no one ever remembers that game
it's one of the least important things
in my life but the lesson I learned is
it's still guiding me today the fact
that go for it
take your shot take your time when you
get that thing you have that opportunity
don't mess it up raise your standard
Apple at the core it's core value is
that we believe that people need passion
and change
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your good suppose to mean
if you want to learn more about Terry
and how to realize your dreams and build
self-discipline I highly recommend the
top ten rules to success Volume one that
we did on him the link is right next to
me continue to believe and I'll see you
there
I exist to show people what's possible